si Pauline effectivement deuxième partie
de ce débat avec le MP Emmanuel bicho
qui représente le président François
sauvadec Colette popar pour partie
socialiste Edward Cavin pour le Front
national Isabelle de Almeida pour le
Front de gauche et Dominique grimper
pour le modem on avait abordé la partie
politique on sait qu'il va y avoir
probablement une spécificité un peu
nouvelle pour cette élection on l'a vu
lors de la législative partielle de
Montbéliard c'est une forme de
tripartisme qui se met en place dans le
pays et avec le mode de scrutin et la
faible participation l'éventualité pour
un des trois piliers de ce tripartisme
alternativement parfois le PS ou l'UMP
peut-être dans d'autres cas le fait de
ne pas être au deuxième tour par rapport
au Front national quand Front national
il sera qu'est-ce qui va se passer
quelle est la position des uns et des
autres par rapport à ça si vous vous
trouvez
exclu d'un deuxième tour Colette Pop Art
d'abord vous avez nous on a toujours été
clair on a toujours été clair mais je
crois qu'avant de penser ne pas être au
deuxième tour il faut quand même essayer
de convaincre les gens de d'y
je travaille depuis longtemps vous le
savez je suis sur le terrain je vois
bien que les gens sont déçus de la
politique je vois bien les gens qui
souffrent dans les quartiers mais je
leur dis de voter dès le 22 mars je me
bats contre l'abstention parce que vous
savez quand il y a beaucoup d'abstention
c'est la démocratie qui souffre c'est la
République qui souffre et donc plutôt
que de prévoir ce qui va se passer nous
on a toujours été très clair sur le
front républicain c'est évident d'autres
leçons beaucoup moins quand même quand
je vois monsieur Wauquiez venir soutenir
un de vos amis candidats sera quand on
dit jeûner en disant sur le troisième
tour à la présidence et ben on acceptera
les voies du Front national pour élire
les présidents dans les conseils
généraux quand j'entends Monsieur
Sarkozy pour lequel sur lequel vous vous
référer tout le temps dire Nini
c'est-à-dire ni le PS ni le Front
national c'est ça et bien nous on est
clair nous nous on se bat contre
l'abstention d'abord et contre le Front
national
mais c'est votre seul programme se
battre contre le Front National et c'est
exactement ça vous l'avez déjà depuis
2001 mon cher jeune homme on avait
montré toutes les missions
c'est le Front national des développe
des arguments qui sont pas dans
l'histoire et la culture de notre pays
la culture l'histoire de notre pays de
la République française jamais été les
tests défendu par le Front national même
s'il y a toujours eu s'il vous plaît je
vous répondrai précisé tour bien entendu
si on y on appellera toujours tout le
monde a voté pour nous mais
quel que soit le candidat qui sera
opposé au Front National au deuxième
tour on voter même l'extrême gauche
parce que cette situation peut se
trouver alors la Côte d'Or peut-être
moins que d'autres départements ailleurs
en France mais cette situation peut se
trouver quel est votre position à vous
moi je vais vous dire d'abord nous on ne
se bat pas ni contre le PS ni contre le
Front national on se bat pour les côtes
de rien puisque ça c'est notre mission
aujourd'hui et je souhaite que ce que ça
soit notre mission demain et si cette
émission peut apporter quelque chose
c'est au moins que vous sachiez
clairement ce que la majorité
départementale fera et ne fera pas dans
le dans les circonstances actuelles mais
ensuite certes mais ensuite mais ensuite
soit très clair
vous vous dites tout et son contraire
laissez manuel bijoux répondre à la
question à laquelle il ne veut pas dire
nettes qui ont le mérite de la cohérence
bien alors oui alors moi je vais vous
dire en côte en Côte-d'Or nous sommes
nous sommes confiants par rapport à ces
élections nous avons nous avons mis en
place très tôt des binômes dans tous les
cantons nous avons de bonnes équipes
nous avons un bilan nous avons un projet
pour les côtes d'Orient et donc pour et
bien écoutez je serai nous serons
peut-être invités à l'issue du premier
tour pour répondre à des questions qui
relèvent aujourd'hui de la politique
fictionnaire en question aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas une question intéressante
aujourd'hui
nous sommes sur le premier donc on
éclaire et nous avons bien l'intention
pour l'instant là sur ce sujet là la
majorités la majorité des
départementales a bien l'intention
d'être présente dans tous les cantons à
l'issue
que nous vous avons posé Isabelle
d'Almeida
je récuse que vous dites parce que quand
même moi ce que je suis aussi assez
atterri aujourd'hui globalement dans le
pays sur ces sur ces élections là c'est
qu'on a le Front national a été banalisé
alors qu'on vient de voir nous nous
avons participé justement à comment à
dire à révéler ce qui vient de se passer
dans certains sur des comptes Facebook
etc ces révélations où il y a des appels
à la haine et à la division écoutez non
on peut regarder donc moi j'en appelle
pas à la responsabilité de tous de tous
mais compris de l'ensemble de l'ensemble
des médias nationaux mais aussi de
responsables politiques de pas mettre
pas banaliser le Front national ne pas
le mettre au centre de la vie politique
voilà et nous avons par exemple parce
que par exemple nous le Front de gauche
avec le Parti communiste nous sommes
présents sur plus de cantons que le
Front National et on est moins invité
dans les émissions
la prestationale donc nous avons
beaucoup moins de vos élections
nationales récemment pour reprendre les
consignes du CSA en l'occurrence
un mot d'Édouard Cavin sur ce qui se
passera si des conseillers généraux
Front national rentrent au conseil
général que ferez-vous avec qui votre et
vous le cas échéant il nous reste une
minute 30 avant les conclusions je
souhaite vivement qu'il y ait des
conseillers départementaux Front
National au sein de cette Assemblée mais
c'est votre seul objectif tout le monde
l'a bien compris tout le monde l'a bien
compris mais je suis très confiant pour
sur le fait qu'il y aura des élus donc
en plus ça fait des couples donc à
chaque fois ça fait deux élus ça a l'air
plus de poids et donc et donc au moment
des élections conseils régionales dans
lequel il y avait eu des élections
présidents compliquées ce qu'on appelle
le 3e tour quelle sera votre troisième
tour votre position 3e tour attention
votre avec votre compte il y a une
charte qui est en train d'être édité
s'il vous plaît il y a une charte qui
est en train d'être édité avec certains
points si
un des candidats à la présidence du
conseil départemental s'engage sur tous
ces points nous appellerons à voter pour
lui c'est aussi simple que ça
vous appellerait à voter pour lui c'est
un ensemble de points madame popart ça
se résume pas uniquement à la fraude
sociale vous le savez bien
vous marquez attention
il nous reste peu de temps dans cette
émission on l'avait prévu pour chaque
émission
de se focaliser tous sur le front
national et Madame dit que c'est les
politiques qui ont vous national au
centre de la vie politique c'est pas les
politiques vous allez conclure c'est
vous qui concluez
Édouard Cavin donc vous allez pouvoir le
dire à la fin donc c'est la règle pour
tous ces tous ces débats 45 secondes de
conclusion pour chacun dans un ordre que
nous avons tiré au sort avant l'émission
avec nos petits papiers en commençant
pour ses conclusions par Colette Pop Art
je vous propose de conclure alors moi je
voudrais m'adresser aux électeurs bon
j'espère que ce débat les a un peu
éclairé bon je sais je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui
souffrent je sais qu'il y a des gens qui
sont aussi déçus par la politique je
voudrais vraiment leur adresser à un
espoir un message d'optimisme l'action
politique n'est pas vaine il faut
laisser croire ça mais pour se battre il
faut des valeurs nous les notes de
valeurs ce sont les valeurs de la
démocratie de la République de la
liberté de l'égalité et du respect ce
sont ça nos valeurs alors j'appelle tous
les habitants tous les électeurs à ne
pas s'abstenir l'abstention et le pire
de nos mots et on sait que l'abstention
profite toujours à l'extrême droite donc
dès le 22 mars votez pour les candidats
de force de gauche du rassemblement de
force de gauche et de progrès de façon à
ce que nous fassions pour la Côte-d'Or
ce que nous avons fait pour Dijon et son
agglomération merci Colette popar
Dominique grimperet à vous oui ben
écoutez j'invite également tous nos
concitoyens à les voter ne serait-ce que
par respect pour notre République je les
invite à voter pour des élus de
proximité ouvert qui ne prône pas le
repliement sur soi on peut certes être
déçu par les deux grands partis il ne
faut pas pour autant porter son suffrage
sur l'obscurantisme que représente le
Front national il faut voter pour des
élus dont le premier souci à l'intérêt
général et non l'intérêt de telle ou
telle partie
et puis surtout important il faut voter
pour des personnes qui représentent
toute la diversité du canton à laquelle
vous appartenez c'est ainsi que c'est ce
que nous proposons avec Madame posière
sur le canton de Fontaine-lès-Dijon
du département et pas des cantons
Isabelle
de mars c'est une étape pour se donner
de la force de la force pour résister
politique d'austérité duquel viennent en
France ou en Côte-d'Or vous avez de la
force aussi pour pour améliorer
la vie quotidienne et je pense que le 22
mars le bulletin de vote pour les
candidats présentés et soutenus par le
Parti communiste et le Front de gauche
peut justement redonner cette force-là
puisque en même temps on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui dans le pays et nous y
travaillons dans les départements nous
souhaitons qu'une gauche nouvelle elle
se met en place qu'elle progresse pour
justement
sortir notre notre pays de la passe donc
le 22 mars j'appelle à voter pour les
collègues candidates qui justement
incarnent cette force nouvelle merci
Isabelle de Almeida dans la suite de nos
conclusions Emmanuel Bissot bien mais
moi ce que je constate c'est que tout
est fait depuis des mois par le
gouvernement pour escamoter cette
élection et bien elle est importante
parce que les compétences du Conseil
Général concernent la vie quotidienne
des et concerne l'avenir de nos
territoires en Côte-d'Or et nous sommes
les seuls à avoir un programme pour la
Côte-d'Or la majorité départementale le
Parti socialiste a veut faire du conseil
général une annexe de la mairie de Dijon
le Front national décline le même
programme dans toute la France et
d'ailleurs un certain nombre de leurs
propositions sont déjà appliqués de
longue date en Côte-d'Or et donc nous
avons un programme en trois points une
aide sociale juste et ferme
la poursuite du soutien au développement
des territoires et la poursuite d'une
politique en faveur des familles et de
leur pouvoir d'achat et nous prenons un
engagement clair et net de ne pas
augmenter les impôts malgré la politique
du gouvernement à l'égard des
collectivités locales et nous tiendrons
ces engagements avec des choix courageux
parce qu'il va falloir être courageux
dans les années à venir merci manuel
bicho et c'est donc Édouard Cavin qui
conclut ses conclusions mais moi je
voudrais dire à tous les coups de rien
pardon qui nous regardent que il faut
arrêter de se laisser embobiner c'est un
petit peu un message d'alerte que je
vais vous lancer vous avez tous regardé
ce débat et vous avez vu des etc qui ne
mène à rien le seul propos des deux
grands partis et des autres c'était de
ces de dire tout sauf le Front national
c'est leur seul programme posez-vous les
bonnes questions si vous voulez vraiment
que ça change je crois qu'il faut
vraiment aller voter et glisser le
bulletin Front national on a fait un
gros travail pour que tous les côtes de
rien puisse voter pour le Front national
donc je vous invite vraiment à mettre un
coup de pied un petit peu dans tout cet
établissement qui qui est complètement
déconnecté des réalités merci Édouard
Cavin merci à tous les cinq d'avoir joué
le jeu du débat
merci Cyril d'être venu participer avec
nous à ce débat on va suivre bien sûr la
campagne dans le bien public bien sûr
oui régulièrement on a commencé très tôt
déjà à faire des des articles sur tous
les sur tous les cantons on a fait un
zoom qui va se terminer à la fin de la
semaine chaque canton a été a été visité
et puis régulièrement sur les
candidatures l'actualité de la campagne
a été découverte voilà que vous pourrez
suivre aussi bien sûr sur France 3 tous
les soirs à 19 heures un journal des
élections avec un gros plan sur des
cantons tests de la Bourgogne près de 17
cantons que nous allons ausculter sur
Internet bien sûr sur c'est le cas aussi
bien sûr sur le site internet du bien
public et puis on en profite pour vous
rappeler qu'il y aura des soirées
électorales comme d'habitude pour ces
élections départementales trois fois 45
minutes au fil de la soirée parce que
ces élections même si elles ne passent
pas forcément le grand public sont
importantes pour pour la démocratique du
pays samedi prochain le rendez-vous
c'est le dernier débat de la série la
Saône-et-Loire un département où il y a
beaucoup de suspens on le sait et puis
voilà rendez-vous même heure au même
endroit sur ce plateau il y aura des
invités aussi merci à tous les cinq
d'avoir consacré un peu de temps à ce
débat bon week-end au revoir